begin with the Pledge of Allegiance with
child leadership
expand
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
right
um
so this is a work session on HB 652
which was retained and I should note
that all the members of the subcommittee
are myself as chair representative di
Lorenzo who is not here she emailed me
to indicate she was Ill she would be
Vice chair and then representative Tripp
and representative Perez who are present
um
so um
one of the um
so the issue is what we should do with
uh this proposed bill that the the uh
the bill would
um amend RSA
91a3 uh Roman numeral 2C to add language
that says that if um
if
a public body goes into non-public
session to discuss matters which
um if discussed in public would
adversely affect the reputation of
certain people
um
uh then the the person whose reputation
would be might be adversely effective
would have a right to be notified
um
uh and be present
uh however have council president speak
on his or her own behalf
um
so that that is the issue
I guess I
um well I guess I'd want to hear from
where what what are members of the
subcommittee
feel about this proposal
he originally heard that I uh
I thought there was uh
it was silly because why would you be a
non-public
if you want someone else to understand
or to know what's being discussed
uh
but then again on the further reflection
if you're discussing someone there there
might be some justification for uh doing
so
uh
but I'm still uh in the middle on this
representative Perez
and you know I think if you were being
accused of something
by law I have a right to know you're
accuser
if you're going to be accused I don't I
think it should be now publicly because
I don't think the entire
town or city should know about it
until it's discussed and made
it's real but I think if you're accused
of something
you should have the right
to be present to hear
what you're being accused of or who's
complaining about you
so that
thank you
put your side in the store I mean
you need to be able to hear your side of
the story I mean that's the whole thing
and if you can't be there you can't do
that I'll give an example I just had a
record in the button here and explain
about me I had to go before
the group here I mean to discuss it
you know whether in the Bible or it was
a Bible it was but you know I mean if I
wasn't there they could just take the
word of this person and
Target by reputation
so I really feel that
you know if you want to make it if it's
non-criminal or criminal or whatever I
think we're discussing I just think
people have a right to know what's being
said about them and what they're being
accused of and
um
I that's how I feel
so you know one of I mean the the
one of the concerns that I had about
about the way the bill was worded thus
far is that it was very expansive
um
in other words beer and and you know I
sort of gave the example I think at one
point of if you're tired I suppose
you're gonna
somehow you uh
you're gonna be talking you know maybe
the town has uh has bought uh
Vehicles made in Japan and they're not
happy with the vehicles and they're
going to say something terrible about uh
they they think that uh uh
well what was that who was the one that
was uh what was the uh the company that
was um
Volkswagen wasn't it that they they were
cooking the books on uh environmental
things so they're gonna so we the town
has bought Volkswagens they're unhappy
uh they think that uh the president of
Volkswagen because you know has been
accused of is uh is a bad guy and
they're gonna talk about him at this at
a meeting so they so they um they're
gonna have the meeting they're gonna
have a closed meeting do they have to
give notice to the president of
Volkswagen
um
my concern is just how how very broad
that was so what what I was thinking is
could we change the language to say
um if the person whose reputation may be
adversely affected is a resident of the
jurisdiction
over which the public body has Authority
so if it's a town it would be the town
if it was a state body it would be
somebody that's a resident of the state
then the person gets no so that um
that was one thing that at least would
kind of cabin in who we're talking about
um but the other thing that that
um
the representative from the admissible
Association was just briefly I was just
discussing it with him before we started
he raises I think a very a really
interesting
point is
I mean example that he gave is suppose
that the
that the town has received information
that the town clerk has been cooking the
books or stealing money or something
like that
um
that
does the does the
and they want to discuss it the
Selectmen want to discuss it do they
have to give the town clerk notice that
they're going to be
um that they're going to be talking
about
um
about that issue because
I mean I would think that would be a
real problem because if they do
um you know maybe the the product
the evidence is going to disappear or uh
there's going to be there's going to be
um
there'll be there would be some problem
with that
um
and
well yeah no no I'm sorry
oh yeah sure sure yeah
thank you
what about if you make it
for
none criminal charges or something I
mean what if you make it for
I mean I don't know it was if the intent
of this bill was to have it for
everything
or was it more the intent for
you know towns was it more the intent
for
um you know nasty stuff that goes on
in a town perhaps and somebody
complaining about somebody or somebody
doing this or doing that I don't know I
mean
can can we ask can we ask questions yeah
yeah I know I think we could sure
representative what was your intent was
it for the entire
everything to cover Encompass everything
I thank you
sure
I I've had an experience where I was on
a on a board in my community and we did
have a situation that did involve
something like that with a member a
Personnel member
get the information you need to discuss
it before you start discussing it
and if that person wants to provide more
information that would help you to
understand it that's that's great maybe
that's what's not necessary
uh
but I know there was there was
definitely every effort made to be
extremely fair to this Personnel member
by the board by the by the director by
everyone involved
and when we discussed it it was the
first time I'd ever heard anything about
it and anything negative about this
person and I would have been happy to
hear from that person and find out more
if that person had an explanation that
would have helped me to understand it
I I unfortunately didn't have that
option
but there was enough evidence to move
forward appropriately
and that was what was done but if a
person
is entrusted with with the funds of the
community you talked about an example of
a state of um sorry a town clerk
and there's some sort of serious
allegation made about embezzlement of
funds or something Criminal
well
they should have an explanation for that
there should be some explanation if the
if they're innocent
and if they're not then they're not
going to be able to make a good case for
that and then the decision makers of
that Community would have to move
forward in the way that they think is
best yeah I guess you know I think the
problem I see with this is that we're
we're
if we drag if we
go along with this proposal remember
you're talking about even
right from the beginning
the person would have the right to
notice I mean if we
you know so if we if you were to adopt
that same reasoning suppose that I go to
the police and I say I think you've
stolen money from me I'm just using you
you know as obviously I I'm just using
this as an example or you go to the
police and you say I think Lynn has
stolen money from me should the police
have to tell me should the police before
they talk to you should I be have a
right to be present
so while while you're talking to the
police about you the fact that you think
I committed a crime because if you if I
have the right to be present there's
going to be first of all you're probably
not going to go to the police or at
least you may not because you might be
afraid of me and secondly
if the police you know I'm I'm gonna if
I know about this from the beginning I'm
going to be in a position to maybe do
things to
you know to sort of Squatch the
investigation and so I mean that's kind
of my concern here
there are laws against that you know
doing things to intimidate Witnesses and
I have been in a situation where I've
had to ask police for some help and and
report a crime
it was difficult when they went to the
person who perpetrated the crime and
asked them for their side of the story
which fair enough that's what they have
to do to investigate that's that's life
there are tough things that we have to
go through I'm sorry that's just the way
it is if you have
enough of a concern to bring this to the
pro appropriate person
with a crime or some kind of a problem
that's happening in your in your
community
then you just have to be tough enough to
also back up what you're saying with
some evidence and if you can't then it's
not going to go anywhere
and just I would just say if you have
that concern then you have to just be
able to to
um take it all the way
yeah I'm not sure that that really
answers the question of whether or not
of why
the person who
is being investigated should be able to
know about the investigation
right from the beginning
because if that but how do you get to
that point how do you get to the point
that you're discussing it as a board
you have to have something that brings
you to that point and that would be the
beginning the beginning was before that
the beginning isn't
the meeting
suppose that
there's a selectman's meeting tonight
and I'm one of the selector
and it's at three o'clock this afternoon
some Town employee comes to me and says
I've got information to suggest that the
clerk is is stealing money from the town
so
tonight at the selectments meeting
tonight
can I tell the other Selectmen about
this and if I do do I have to notify the
clerk why we're going to talk about the
fact that somebody is alleged you've
stolen money that doesn't give you the
48 hours that this bill
requires it doesn't give you the 48
hours to notify the person that you're
talking about who you think has
um
embezzled
yeah
I think
first of all
if you get that information I think the
first thing you're going to say well
I need some evidence of this before I
bring it bring it to the council I need
evidence you can't just
say I think
representative Lynn is stealing money
you have to say well give me the
evidence of that and once you have the
evidence and it's appropriate then to
bring it to a
meeting
then the person could be just like the
police have to have the evidence before
they go after somebody I think what this
is going to do it's going to stop
I don't like that representative so I'm
going to say that she did this or that
that's what it's going to stop because
too much of that goes on too much
accusing people of thing goes on
and
um and I think this will stop it if they
know that when it's talked about whether
it be at the Town level or the state
level
that they're going to allow to be
present to defend themselves
I mean
we do that here in the State House when
an accusation is made against you you're
there you're it when it's discussed
you're there this was put before you
yeah my concern is really I think
you know you you say that the
that the the the if I got that
information as a selectman I would have
to you know I would say I need more and
I don't disagree with you I would be
saying that but this but this would say
that I can't discuss it
I can't discuss the fact that employee X
came to me with this information I can't
tell the other
the other uh Selectmen at a select
boards meeting in a private session that
I've gotten this information and say
look and say look you know I don't know
whether this is true or not I've asked
the person to get more to give me the
the the details but
this would seem to say that that I can't
do that without letting the person know
that they're being investigated in other
words the the problem is there's there's
no question that at some point somebody
who's being accused of something if
there's really something there sure
they've got to be notified they've got
to have an opportunity to be heard I
mean I don't disagree with that at all
but the problem is
at
during the time when there's an
investigation going on
they
they I mean they shouldn't know that
they're being empowered they may not it
may not be appropriate for them to know
that they're being investigated because
then they can take steps that would be
might undercut the investigation that's
that's what I'm sort of concerned about
perhaps you should gather more evidence
before you get to that point where
you're discussing it with with others
with others
okay I think that's the best way to move
forward with such a thing
like I said the board that I was on
we had more evidence before it was
discussed with us
there was evidence before it came to us
we were told about the situation later
and and like I said if that person that
we were talking about was there I would
have been happy to get there
explanation of it if they wanted to give
it
I felt like that often when we discussed
employees
that if there was any problem I would
really like to hear from from them and
get their side of it
what um
again the municipal Association
representative suggested that one of the
I mean we might be able to
um
we might be able to at least somewhat
cure the issue by
um
amending section A of subsection two to
not only include that that's the section
that says where you can be a non-public
session to discuss the dismissal
promotion or compensation of an employee
or the investigation of any charges
against him or her
He suggests
changing that to include not only
employees but also officials
of the jurisdiction
um
so that
if you if you
amended that to include
you know to include not just employees
but officials of the jurisdiction
um then that would then in the situation
where
that there's the the in the example I
gave you could withhold disclosure to
the to the person that's sort of that's
for lack of a better term the target of
the investigation pursuant to that
section so
um
I mean what if we did that and then made
the Chan and then left
C
as you propose it perhaps with the
limitation of the residence requirement
what would you say about that
can you go over that again
right but that was yeah just go through
it again so a so subsection a of the law
as it now exists says that you can be in
non-public session
for the following reason
um
to discuss quote the dismissal promotion
or compensation of any Public Employee
or the disciplining of such employee or
the investigation of any charges against
him or her
unless the employee one has the right to
a meeting and two requests that the
meeting be open in which case the
request shall be granted well an
employee doesn't have a right to a
meeting if you're talking about
investigating you're you're talking
you're just talking about investigating
the employee if you're gonna if you're
going to fire you if you're going to
take some action against them maybe they
do but if you're just going to
investigate them they don't have any
right to a meeting so what
um what Natchez suggested was what if we
amend that section right now it applies
only to employees what if we change what
if we mended it so that it would also
apply to officials meaning like planning
board like a town clerk or the planning
board member or Zoning Board member the
town selectman that kind of thing how
about the public
um what about the public because the
public gets drawn in very often to
incriminating things during not in
public as well
I don't really have a problem with an
official but the the original
reason for why this was of interest to
me was I got drawn into something and I
was not it was not in my role as a state
representative it was in
I was just a member of the public in
that role where I spoke to a library
director in my community and
there was an investigation on whether or
not I had
influenced well the other person that
spoke to the library director at that
time there was an investigation about
that person who's here with us today and
whether or not that person
um
bullied the library director into
canceling a program which did not happen
the investigation showed that that did
not happen and that would have been good
for the town counselors to know that and
to hear from that person
who was
a library trustee at that time at that
library and had every right to talk to
the director about a program
but of course not violate any state laws
about
bullying them or anything or influencing
them to do something that they they
didn't have the right to do and that's
not what happened the the that was the
investigation found that to not be true
it would have been a great Savings of
money in taxpayer funds to my community
to for the Town Council to have heard
from that person
um when that happened
so yes official would
would cover it if you wanted to say that
anybody else have anything that they
want to yes please
and can you just identify yourself
please I'm Lorraine lindenberg from
Derry yes
um the attention of HB 652 was not for
uh employees
because there already is under 91 A3
C2 all right for employees of the town
this was meant for private citizens
you know so the example that was used by
the nhama
was already in this bill
it's already in in law under the what
these uh well no it's not because a
applies only to employees an employee
would not include somebody like a like a
planning board member or the selectman
or
um or town clerk or that well the town
clerk is an employee
they're elected officials but they're
also you know paid employees
uh but that example is already is
already in the law
the HB 652 was for basically private
citizens who may be accused of something
um and the council goes into not public
I believe that you know a private
citizen should be notified and allowed
to attend to be able to speak on their
own behalf
and there is no uh law in 91a that does
provide this mandatory can I just ask
you a
what I'm
I'm really concerned about is this
I certainly agree
that if the town
you know if if the town is going to take
some action against somebody in other
words if they're going to say
you know I don't I'm I'm sure I'm not
sure I understand the details of the
situation example if for example if the
town we're going to say some person is
going to be barred from entering the
library or bards from entering a school
or uh where you know we're gonna We're
Not Gonna uh
uh contract with that person anymore or
whatever I certainly think that before
the town should could do that they would
the the person has a right to be heard
and to put on a defense
but that doesn't happen representative
Lynn unfortunately will you live in a
small town too unfortunately that
doesn't happen and what happens is in a
circumstance like this I didn't know
about that circumstance but there are
circumstances that happen that you know
a people are human they unfortunately
private citizens who live in a community
need something to protect them too
because not all Town officials like all
the citizens and the problem that you
can run into I mean I know very well
that my Town Council chair does not like
me and he's very obvious about it and
has done some really different difficult
things
the private citizen should have a right
to be able to be present if the council
members are talking about them because
someone said well uh Christine did this
or Christine did that and we need to see
what we're going to do about it I think
the private citizen has a right to
to be there to say well that's not
really what happened you know that and I
have this person that was with me that
can tell you that's not what happened so
it's about due process being able to
hear what what you're being accused of
and being able to speak on your own
behalf
representative Bryant
were you informed that they were going
to be talking about you
I was not informed and I found out
afterwards there was an investigation
when I got a phone call from a lawyer
when I was out of state taking care of
some really important family business
and I couldn't really
give it the attention that I it deserved
um
all I could do was tell that lawyer
please read all of the library trustee
meeting minutes and review when I spoke
to the Town Council about this issue
yeah and what I think happened was one
town counselor probably went and told
the others what
happened at a library trustees meeting
what allegedly happened alleged what
what they thought happened
they gave their story about what
happened at a library trustees meeting
um
when
the other Town counselors were not at
that meeting I don't think the minutes
were out yet and I I know Town
counselors are very busy and can't read
every single solitary thing that happens
in the community and may have just
assumed that this perspective that was
presented to them was the only one when
I found it to be quite inaccurate
to say the least it appears to me if you
look at
the first sentence in subsection C
is that uh
address switch if discussed in public
would likely affect adversely the
reputation of any person other than a
member of the public body themself
unless such person requests an open
meeting it would seem that
there would have to be some knowledge by
the person who's being discussed
before the meeting
well that's
that's what I'm talking about the uh if
the
public body is going to go into
non-public to discuss someone it appears
that
uh if the person is being discussed
this person that's being discussed has
to know about it otherwise they would
never have an opportunity to request an
open meeting
you know so it it seems that what
happened here is the the Town Council
aired in conducting the uh
uh
non-public meeting because if they're
going to be talking about you they
should have given you an opportunity to
request an open meeting right but that
that pertains to employees public
employees and I agree with the nhma that
um you could add officials to that
subsection but HB 652 is more for
private citizens not for public
employees since there already is a law
in place for public employees
and they do have the right to uh to a
meeting and to decide whether it should
be enclosed
uh meeting or in public meeting they
have a right to decide but a private
citizen uh does not
they don't have the right to a hearing
at all a meeting at all
and and just as the spirit of that law
is to protect the the career and the
reputation of public employees I think
that
regular citizens deserve the same
opportunity I feel I felt afterwards
like the situation that caused me to be
interested in this was based on lies
that I had no way of rebutting at that
at that time that's how I felt about it
that that it had to have been presented
inaccurately in order for the other Town
counselors to have voted to have an
investigation which was utterly
unnecessary and a waste of taxpayer
funds so you know I guess here here's
the thing that I'm I'm trying to sort of
think through this because I think in
some sense we're talking about
at least somewhat different things yes
right the
in other words
before I don't have any questions I said
a moment ago I don't have any question
that before some adverse action
should be taken against somebody
you know the examples I gave the first
obviously the person needs
to it needs to have an opportunity to
for due process to be able to you know
to to
um
respond
but
the thing I'm not I I think I disagree
with is when you say for example when
you said representative O'Brien vet
they you you had the right to know
before that they were gonna do an
investigation or before they did an
investigation why why should you know
that in other words why is it any
different
than supposed that instead of going to
the selectments for the selectment to
discuss this whoever had this complaint
went to the police
do you have a right to know before the
police do it take any you know before
they arrest you or take any action that
you're being investigated because that
would be a really a major difference
from existing law
as I as I previously spoke up
that's part of the investigation is to
speak to all sides and that's what the
police do when they do those sorts of
Investigations about serious crimes sure
but they don't in other words but if if
somebody accused accused me of robbery
for example the police they may decide
to speak to me but they don't do that
that they don't tell me that at the
outset they go gather the evidence
just you know to see if they've got a
case and usually the the last person
that gets talked to is the person that's
the that's the um that is Accused
because the police try to gather the
information from other people first and
they may have that information but
speaking to you may be very important to
that investigation you may be able to
say something of very high importance
such as I was not even in town I was not
even in the state when that robbery
occurred exactly but but but the problem
is
the analogy that I'm drawing is you
would say that the police have to when
Once when somebody comes into the police
and says Lynn stole some money from me
the first thing the police have to say
wait a minute stop we can't really talk
to you right now we have to call Lynn
and tell him that you're complaining
against him that's sort of the
equivalent for the selectman's meeting
that you're talking about and that's the
thing that I have some problem with
because it seems to
it seems to it the implications of that
I think could be
could be pretty significant do you feel
the same way about
about
speaking to employees and having
employees
present when there there's going to be a
hearing about them do you feel that
because that is in in law right now and
would you would you do you think that
should not exist
no
but whether it's not it is not the law
now
that if you're going if the if the
Selectmen are going to be talking
about an employee not taking any action
but just in other words
talking about an employee that they have
to notify the employer I'm not aware of
anything in the law that says they but
that's the case why don't you make it
before any action any any
is taken that might
against the person or that might blah
blah blah the person's um
reputation
what about if you had it say add the
officials that's fine
Ed is a resident of the jurisdiction of
the municipality
that's fine
but in instead of have it say that
before
any action is taken like before they
called a lawyer before they did that
before any type of action that would
directly and I don't know the legal
terms you guys do that all the time to
me
that would uh
have any possibility of being taken
against the public the citizen
or that would in any way you know do
something about their um
you know their reputation
because public sessions if I'm in a
public non-public session and I'm a
council meeting I'm not supposed to go
out and say hey guess what I heard I
heard the general right okay right I
agree so if it's in a non-public session
they're supposed to keep their mouth
shut about it but before they take any
action of any type whether it be
criminal or non-criminal or would just
do something to their reputation that
then the person has the right
to a meeting to a meeting I think that's
fair okay that sound all right so let me
announce
I mean I think that's fair too that
makes sense to me the only question is
where
proposing some language yes I see
somebody in the back that has
come on up okay and somehow yeah you
don't don't leave you you may have
something to respond but
um
we'll have you back okay
the other thing you're going to have to
include the public in this the public
isn't included in this
foreign
I am general counsel for the office of
professional licensor and certification
and we oversee I think 180 000
individual licensees in the state with
around 200 000 different license types
so we're very much interested in the
outcome of this bill with me is attorney
Ricky and medley and she is sort of my
Counterpoint she or counterpart she uh
provides advice to the professional
boards that the office oversees it's an
interesting where this conversation
turned because the whole time we're
having this conversation I'm thinking a
lot of the opportunities to be heard are
covered they're just not covered under
91a they're covered under 541a the
administrative procedure act at least
the state level so I pulled up the
definition in 541a one an agency uh
Roman numeral two agency means each
state board commission Department
institution officer or any other state
official or group other than the
legislature or the courts authorized by
law to make rules or to determine
contested cases and what it sounds like
based on this conversation is that
we're interested in expanding now I
haven't done any kind of legal analysis
to see if that definition would apply at
the municipality level but it sounds
like that's what we're talking about is
expanding 541a the administrative
procedure act to apply at the local
level
and
I I don't think 91a is the appropriate
statute for for what we're trying to do
based on the conversation I've heard and
I also think the language has written
creates a lot of a lot of problems and
um
for for the way things function at the
state level right now and I can give you
some examples if you'd like them some of
them you've actually already talked
about today so when I'm when I'm hearing
the conversation I thought maybe
maybe we're looking at the long wrong
law in order to try and solve this
problem
and I wanted to
throw 541a or something similar in the
mix
as you seem to be going down that route
okay
now I don't know if I made any friends
with the municipalities did I come up
and saying that but I wanted to put it
out there
right well what I mean what would if if
we made the changes that representative
Perez has suggested why I think I think
the changes still make the law
too expansive and I'll give you a couple
of reasons why and I also submitted some
testimony back in March when we were
hearing this bill I can I can send that
again no I think I I think we well I I
think I have okay I had it at home on my
kitchen counter it's a good read if you
need to go to sleep
um
so we've got a couple of issues one of
them is emergency hearings under the
lplc statutes three ten twelve four uh
also I believe 541 a where's the
emergency oh it's in my other work it's
over here
541-a colon 30 Roman numeral three and
what that covers is
um emergency hearings when an individual
has been identified as a an immediate
threat to the public a complaint comes
in the office learns about something the
board learns about something they can do
a hearing ex parte and suspend a license
that day and then they have to hold a
hearing to see if that license or that
suspension should be upheld within 10
days
um but I don't think the language has
proposed would account for that type of
thing at all the initiation of
additional disciplinary proceeding and
you've sort of talked about this a lot
representative but I do want to say sort
of the way our process works a complaint
comes in we check to see if there's a
claim the investigators go out and
investigate they put together a
recommendation to proceed or not then
it's brought before the board and I
suppose a good equivalent would be sort
of a grand jury indictment and so I
think the way the language as proposed
is written it would be like having the
individual under investigation sitting
in on that grand jury deliberation and I
I don't think
the system is going to be able to
function that way
also the language as written after the
public hearing because there is still
notice and opportunity to be heard if
the state is going to take action
against the individual the licensee
whomever
that notice and opportunity isn't in 91a
it's in 541a it's that administrative
procedure act I have a question sure
we're talking about the public we're not
talking about people who work
credentials we're talking right but the
language in as proposed would expand
any person could be somebody could be
one of those people it would also
because we are subject to 91a so it
would if we if we expand that language
we're still going to have to follow it
uh administrative procedure act aside
so it's going to touch on the licensees
it's going to touch on the systems in
place now let me make a comment sure
everybody's predicted except for the
except for the private citizen that's
something
I I just the private citizen
I I we need to protect the private
citizen from false accusations by towns
by people by this and that right now
we're not protecting them
a private citizen and the way of the
world is getting worse and worse you
know I have said many times sitting here
what about the or what about the
I understand that's protecting that's
protecting the municipality and all the
people that work for it but it's not
protecting the people who are living in
the town who it's protecting them it's
not protecting me as a private citizen
living in a town I want protection under
91a that I'm not going to be falsely
accused of something because
representative O'Brien doesn't like me
you know I I want that protection this
is a way to give me that protection
and I understand it may but what about
the person if you they're I'm sure
they're tired of hearing me say that
what about what about the layperson what
about the kittens what about the babies
well I don't necessarily disagree with
that I'm just I just don't think that
this language is
necessarily the best path forward to to
get those Protections in place without
blowing up at least at the state level
the processes that are already in place
because of 541a and that's why I came up
initially I think maybe something
similar to the administrative procedure
act would be a better fit for the
problem we're trying to solve than a
modification to 91a which is going to
touch the municipalities but it's also
going to touch all of the state agencies
and and really bring a lot of good
processes including due process notice
opportunity to be heard to their knees
right this this could it's not an
exaggeration to say this could really be
devastating to the way the state is
operating now if we want to expand that
to the municipality level you know I I
can't take a position on that as a as a
member of the executive branch but I do
think something more along the lines of
the administrative procedure act would
would get you where you wanted to be so
you can put a private citizen in there I
mean you can make it covered so a
private citizen would be covered under
it I suppose
to get due process and that's the
conversation we can have but if you and
I'm just brainstorming here right I'm
this is based on the conversation we
heard today but what if you expanded I'm
not making friends here right now I know
this but 541a1
um agency if you expanded that to
include
a municipality or government at any
level in the state then the notice and
opportunity be heard the time limits for
taking action on applications all of
those things would
by nature of including them in the
definition be expanded to the local
levels and it would give that private
citizen if the local level agency was
going to take action against them it
would expand
and give them those protections I
understand what you're saying but again
I'm not a lawyer I was a nurse for 42
years I don't think that's Apples to
Apples I think that's apples to oranges
that's just my first impression I would
have to do more research on it but
well all right so you know what um
what if uh I'm you know I I think your
point is a good one about your the take
action sort of idea the the the
the the issue I'm having is just is just
exactly how to word it so that it
accomplishes what you what you uh have
in mind
um
but um if we in other words if we did if
we made C
uh
RSA 91a3 Roman numeral 2C if we change
the language there
um
so that it it basically said
you have you have to give notice to the
person who's being
talked about before some action not just
simply because they're being talked
about but before some action
is taken against them
um
what are you recommending maybe taking
some of the provisions of 41A that apply
to the state and then bringing them to
91a at the municipality level
because that sort of sounds right like
like
the way the system works now you've got
that system analogous to a grand jury
indictment
um
well this there is there's notice an
opportunity to be heard there at the
state level and I'm talking about the
state level why can't you add unless
life limit something you know you know
unless they're going to kill somebody
you know or hurt themselves or something
well I also think the language it opens
up
deliberations after uh notice and
opportunity and a hearing have occurred
those boards can sit there and delivery
I I read the language as proposed to be
expansive to allow the individual in the
room
uh there's ex parte communication issues
there because hearing Council wouldn't
necessarily the person who prosecuted
the case wouldn't necessarily be able to
be in the room
um and then also I mean even with with
processing licensing applications if
somebody has a criminal background check
and the board has to review that too and
they're making a determination that
could be in non-public depending on the
crime the accusation whatever it may be
essentially if if we let that person in
the room we're we're kind of creating
situations where they've become
contested cases without giving proper
notice to the other side state agency
based on 541a
so so I
I just we need to be very careful about
what we do with 91a because we're trying
to solve what it what I'm hearing is
problems at the local level but the
language as proposed is going to impact
everyone in the state
but we're talking but that's what we're
trying to do we're trying to think right
the
John Doe who lives in
a town of 50 people that's who that's
who we're here to protect right okay and
I don't agree with the fact that you
said you know a
background check that's part of the
investigation
that you would have before you took
action I'm saying before you take action
you can gather all the information you
want I'm saying have it before action
before you hire a lawyer to go against
them or prosecute them or before you
kick them out of the Town out of you
know say they can't go near the library
or before you tell them they can't come
walking into the building I mean due
process is not followed all the time we
had private citizen two private citizens
that were not allowed on Tom property
horrible horrible horrible incident in
our town that's
you know I mean
but we've got to protect the private
citizen and I understand the credentials
and stuff but you can do all the
investigation you want all I'm asking is
that once you've done that investigation
before you decide to prosecute or not do
anything or or whatever you decide to do
that person has a right even if you're
not going to do anything the person
should have a right to come in and say
hey we we got this complaint we're not
going to do we looked around we're not
going to do anything but what's your
side of the story
a very motherhood in apple pie I'm I'm
for the you know
the private citizen needs to be
protected
I happen to be one with a big mouth so I
know
well my response to that would be at
least at the state level I think that
private citizen does have those
protections with the notice and
opportunity to be heard I can't speak at
the municipal level
and but that's again why I keep bringing
up 541a administrative procedure act I
to me that's more the solution than a
change to 91a
all right privacy can I can I ask a
question of you representative Perez so
what you're suggesting is that uh
before anyone be discussed
in a non-public meeting that you make a
public notice saying that they're going
to be discussed that's not what I'm
saying yes it appears to be no what I'm
saying is
you two are the council members and and
representative O'Brien
O'Brien I have a complaint
representative Perez because she did
this this and this and I think she's
doing this this and this okay so now you
council members get together you discuss
it you look into it you you know gather
the information you want to you come to
a decision that we're either going to
say this is baloney and we're not going
to do anything or we're going to say gee
we need to tell her she can't come to
Town Council meetings anymore or this
that at that point before you do
whatever you have decided to do you call
me in private citizen Perez to come and
say
private citizen O'Brien did this this
and this and this this is what we have
found
what are your thoughts
is that what you're looking for
yeah right but you but you see I I mean
I I think the problem here is this
because it really
nine remember 91a is simply a disclosure
it doesn't it's not it it's the
disclosure law it doesn't have anything
to do with the law of when you can take
action or not it's just a disclosure law
that's and so
this I mean I agree with you I I the
scenario you just pointed out I agree
with you completely but I think what
the proposed amendment
it to use your scenario the proposed
amendment that's that that uh I mean the
the proposed amendment accomplished by
652 it would say
that
when
if we're the board of Selectmen and
somebody is going to come in and say
representative Perez did something wrong
but leave the representative out of it
okay somebody's going to come in and say
Ms Perez a citizen of Londonderry did
something wrong
what this amendment would say is
we can't even have that discussion oh
let's make it let's modify it so that it
could be that way so that
have the discussion but before we take
any action against
right right exactly right but I guess
what I think what I'm saying is this law
doesn't say now that they can take
action without telling there's nothing
in this law that says the way it is the
way it's written right now that says
they can take some action against
citizen Perez
without without giving her due process
yeah that's this is just a question of
of can they have a discussion in a
non-public session before they can take
you know before they can take action
against you they can't if they were
going to say you're barred from going
into the library or you know they they
can't do that without giving you some
some due process I mean that would seem
to me that's probably unconstitutional
well it happens all the time
see them not in their heads it happens
every single day
every single day they do that what kind
of things happen What kinds of things
happen
I just explained one I uh you can't come
on Town property
two could you elaborate on that a little
bit well I really
oh
it had nothing to do with me but it's a
court case
um
so I probably should but I mean
there's all kinds of things that happen
you know where you go to public session
and if the if if
you can talk for three minutes but it's
allowed for five of we're done we don't
want to hear that stuff happens all the
time all the time
are you agreeing with me that it's
really sad what goes on
in the name of being a whatever in a
town it's very very sad to me what goes
on and
um
I I just think people have a right to be
able to know I mean
I don't know it's just it it's I just
think people have a right to know what
groups Municipal groups
town councils or this group or the
planning board or this port are saying
against them
because John Doe said it and have no
right to be able to say blah blah blah
you know I mean I'm going to a meeting
tomorrow night then I know they're not
going to be happy about but they want to
put 96 homes on dirty land but just
don't eat the dirt or drink the brown
Water really
I'm sure they're going to tell me I
can't talk anymore but
I'm worried about the kids that are
going to live in that area so I mean
it's it's it's very sad I worry about
the Next Generation a lot that's why all
right anyone else anything else anyone
wants to say
uh can I ask sure uh you rattled off a
bunch of numbers about uh the uh you
spoke faster than I could write I'm
sorry
it was five oh administrative procedure
Act is 541a
yeah and then colon one is the
definitions and Roman numeral two is
where agency is defined and then you
have to get more into the statue but uh
29 29a 30 they create the due process
they create the notices narrowed it a
little bit for me so that okay because
before it was this big and now it's this
big okay uh
I'm also happy and unfortunately I can't
I can't speak to what happens at the
municipal level I don't work at the
municipal level
um but I I do think that I do think the
language as proposed is going to have
real unintended consequences at the
state level where the due process is
happening
sure do Town Charters supersede
Municipal law I'm not ready to answer
that question
can I ask uh that's can you come up for
a second can I ask you a question
so can I'm just wondering if you could
tell us generally my impression and but
I could very well be wrong is that
the way the law is now
a municipality for example may be able
to go into non-public session to to have
a discussion about
something where where you know they're
going to talk about somebody in an
adverse way okay
that
that does not mean and correct me if I'm
wrong that does not mean that they can
then decide we're going to take some
action against the person without
giving the person due process I mean is
that is that correct correct correct so
if they in other words if they have in
in the example that gave Horizon if they
if the selectman had a meeting and said
you know we think somebody's doing
something wrong in the library
they may be able to have that discussion
without notifying the person that
they're going to have that discussion
correct but if they were then to decide
you know we're going to Bar
Ms X or Mr X from the library
can they do that without
uh giving the person an opportunity to
respond
um
so
I think that's
possible because it's Town property and
they're the
governing body for the town so
essentially
and let me give you let me give you a
couple different examples that might
help illustrate how this breaks out so
in your example with the library
you know if I go in the library and I
start throwing books around and you know
acting like a crazy person
I think it's possible for the governing
body to say
you know Nate you can't come in here
again but of course I can always
challenge that I can always either go in
there and then they'll be it court case
presumably for because they'll charge me
with trespass or I could simply go to
court and say they're illegally barring
me from this property
um
to go back to something else that that
has been talked about extensively it
seems like
one of the kind of major points here is
that due process issue
um and I just want to emphasize
our position
um for that and let me go back to my
town clerk scenario so imagine I'm the
town clerk you have an employee comes in
and and you're the board and they say
hey nature is you know embezzling money
and what he's doing is some people are
coming in they're paying their car
registrations in cash and he's just
pocketing that
one of the things that I want to make
sure is protected is something I think
that the the state does too although I
can't speak for them which is that you
know once you receive that accusation
you're going to have to discuss what to
do as a board and come up with a plan
and
whatever that plan is will probably
involve some sort of investigation and a
good investigator will probably come and
talk to me at some point in time to ask
my side of the story that's not required
by
any existing law that's general practice
obviously if I'm actually embezzling
money the smart thing to do is deplete
the fifth but
as part of the investigation
um
I would potentially get to tell my side
of the story or it's possible the
investigation starts they interview the
employee they realize the employee is
not doing their job and they're mad at
me because I'm functioning effectively
as their boss and therefore there's no
credibility to this and they close the
investigation
so I think there are several different
scenarios that the language presented
here touch on
um I don't have any objection to
clarifying anything around due process
to make sure that due process is
followed in scenarios where there where
some action is going to be taken I think
that's appropriate that's certainly
required by the Constitution
and so I don't have any issues with any
sort of statutory changes that that may
clarify that process right but that
presumably that any changes in that
regard would not be to the right to know
correct I mean it would be in some other
correct some other statute dealing with
what uh right when when this when a town
can take action against somebody and I
agree completely with your
characterization earlier of the right to
no law as a disclosure law of when
things are going to be disclosed versus
when they're not and and that
um
that summary that you gave of the law
can uh the the scenario to described
would be uh the the town has the
authority to Bar someone from the
library if since it is Tom property and
they might be doing something wrong but
the situation here is not
that it was uh attending a trustee
meeting which is a public meeting and
speaking
you know
now can they bar someone from a public
meeting
well you would have to analyze that
under the traditional public forum
analysis under the Constitution
I am not aware of any constitutional
cases where someone has been able to be
barred from a public forum
because that's the situation
correct
well yes
well is it was that the situation that
we're we're discussing no oh
okay well then don't understand
correctly
good question do you know if charters
supersede the law
because
very often we hear in different towns
saying well our chart Charter allows
that our Charter allows that our Charter
allows that
so let me give you an example
I live in a community and we have
Community rules okay and regulations
okay
and then we have town
okay and then we have state I know that
if we try to put something in here at
this level that is against what the town
says we can't it doesn't hold water I
want to see if a town puts a charter
together
if that they can if I could turn around
say well that's against the law the
state law so therefore that doesn't hold
water so what I'm asking is can you have
things in your town chart or that don't
go follow the state law I would assume
the answer is no
you were Mr lawyer over there
we are not a home rule state the
legislature has allowed towns to adopt
Charters under uh chapter 43 BC and d
and they've allowed basically a limited
home rule and so there are certain
things that are required in those
Charters and certain things those
Charters may contain and those are all
spelled out in the statutes thank you
all right thank you very much thank you
all right anybody else have anything
they want to say yes
we've gone off on a lot in a lot of
directions here
um
and thinking about
uh what the gentleman from the office of
professional licensure was I think
that's is that correct
certification is was discussing uh if
you could
add on onto onto this that that would
this would not apply to those procedures
would not apply to procedures defined in
our RSA 541a then it wouldn't affect
um profession professional licensure
administrative actions
it's a little cumbersome but I go back
to and I always like to go back to this
when I think about any issue how a
regular person would
interpret this law and find the laws
that Define their rights and I I go back
to when I was in my 20s and I was
working full-time and I had a little
baby and I was trying to find state laws
about about an issue that was very
important to me
it was very difficult for me I didn't
have training I remember I was working
full-time and I would be sitting at my
bench
um I made musical instruments at the
time and I ran a little machine shop and
I thought I do not have 40 hours a week
like the people in prison have to read
state law and I was very frustrated by
that and I would spend my evenings at
this at the library looking for
information and trying to find
definitions for things that I did not
know like habeas corpus how do I Define
that I was really frustrated by that I
just remember feeling very overwhelmed
and
annoyed that any that whenever anything
wasn't easy to Define and easy to
understand I was annoyed and I was I was
mad I was mad about it
uh
I want to keep things as simple as
possible for the regular people of our
state to understand what their rights
are and everything that that
representative Perez was talking about
I agree wholeheartedly with with your
sentiments thank you for bringing that
forward and thinking about the regular
people of our state who sometimes feel
short
cited and forgotten about
and misunderstood and so busy with their
lives that they can't be here to discuss
everything that we are
just that I have found grin I'm new in
all of this and it's sometimes
overwhelming to me but the other thing
that I have found is that everybody else
has somebody representing them
but Joe John Doe does not have anybody
represented him and the the thing that
comes out all the time was well they can
you know they can get a lawyer they can
get a lawyer
John Doe with two kids working full-time
cannot afford to get a lawyer
so
let's not put it them in a position that
they have to fight for every single
thing and they understand what they're
allowed to do
I had to get a babysitter I had to get
my mother-in-law to help me watch my
kids sometimes so that I could go to the
library and look things up this was
before the internet but still it would
be the same thing now maybe I could do
it while the baby was sleeping in the
other room I could maybe a little easier
now but still
not having a legal background trying to
understand things I felt overwhelmed and
it was hard and I wouldn't so I I want
to make sure that everything is easy to
understand for regular people who are
not lawyers I try to I try to think of
that as much as possible
thank you very much
all right
um so I guess
um
I'll see I mean I'm I'm still very
you're Mike you're Mike's not as well
I'm still
what
I'm still very troubled by this bill I
have to say honestly because I'm the
more I think about the implication
because what this bill seems to say is
and I think this would be a major change
to the law
members of the public
have the right to know when a public
body
in non-public sessions so it can't be
disclosed it's not that they cannot
publish what they're doing to anybody
but a member of the public has the right
to know when a public body is saying bad
things about them
even though they a can't disclose what
they're saying to anybody and B they
haven't taken any action any concrete
action in any way against the person
and that
the implications of that seem to me to
be
you know I I could see real problems
stemming from that if we were to say
that they do have that right
um
yes
HB 652 is modeled almost word for word
from Massachusetts law
their right to know law I have a copy of
it yeah no no I understand that but I
think that Massachusetts is one of very
few states that have done this right I
don't think that I don't think there's
anywhere near in fact it may be the only
other state that's done it
I'm sure it's not but that's the one
that I investigated
to make sure you know to see if there
was precedence
but um
the 91a laws do protect public employees
but they don't protect private citizens
from being discussed in non-public
sessions without their knowledge you
know with without their knowledge
um you know and this is just 652 is
simply
just to notify a private citizen
uh which was the individual
of this but not public meeting and that
they would be discussed now you're going
into non-public meeting uh under the
exceptions of you know there are several
exceptions and it's usually the
reputation exception
all right but what you want to do is
make sure that this person has the right
to hear what's being set against them
and the right to be able to speak on
their own behalf before action is taken
right but but this said but you see
that's that that is the that is really
the problem of of this this is a
disclosure law you are if we pass the
Bill even with all the suggestions that
we've changed that we've talked about if
you if you pass this bill
we're saying that they have a right
to know
even before they they have a right to
know simply because of the fact you're
going to discuss them whether there is
you know whether there is any
um something in other words in in if we
pass this this amendment as as drafted
somebody comes in and says
um they they go into non-public sessions
and somebody says one of the Selectmen
says you know uh
um somebody told me that um
citizen Smith is uh is uh
destroyed destroying some property in
the public park
and all the other selectmers say that
the person that told you that is crazy
we're not taking any further action end
of it they do they do nothing it's all
gone they they you know it it takes it
takes five minutes and nothing happens
if we pass this bill the the per the
person would have the right to know
about that
about the fact that they were having
when they would not be able to have that
discussion without calling the without
notifying the person and that's my
concern if there if there is no action
taken
why do you have the right to know
but how do you know that no accident is
going to be taken unless you bring it up
and I should have the right to be there
to hear what's being said about me you
know because
I don't know why but let me ask you if
that's true
then why is it then why isn't it the
case if I if I suppose I'm you know
again I'm just making this example up
suppose that I think
that um the representative from the
municipal Association
um uh I I I say he assaulted me as we
were coming in here this morning
and I go to the police and I go so I I'm
I'm going to go down to the Concord
Police and I'm going to report him to
the Concord Police
does he have the right to be there
before I talk to the Concord Police
that's a police accident assault is a
police action not not a municipal board
so so you're going off into other
directions that have nothing to do with
91a no no no no but but if we if we pass
this amounts suppose that
instead of instead of
going to the police about the about this
suppose it happens in the con suppose
instead of going to the police about
this is we're supposed we're this is the
this is the Windham select board and I
believe that that I was just assaulted
by uh by the the municipal Association
representative and I want to go into
non-public session to mention that that
I'm you know I intend to uh that we
should
um that the select board should take
some action
all I'm talking about is discussing it
not that they actually take the action
but simply discussing why do they why
does he have a right to be present for
that
I think we're going around in circles
and
we need to get in if we got an amendment
on this where it would be the person
would be notified if an action was to be
taken that means there would be a
meeting about this and then if an action
was taken to be taken and if you're
assaulted by someone wouldn't you just
why why not just go straight to the
police why would you stick around for a
meeting or something I mean you deal
with that and differently it wouldn't be
a municipal board matter
I mean my problem is that the way this
is worded it would it it would it could
apply in that circumstance so that you
wouldn't be able to have well if you're
not taking an action
then if we put in get an amendment on
this that that the person
has the right to a uh to know that
you're going to be discussing them
before an action is decided upon and
before any adverse action yeah then that
wouldn't apply
okay well how would you know there's
going to be an action taken before you
discuss it
you're you're not going to vote as a
board to investigate and spend Town
money on on a legal investigation hiring
a law firm that's an action that's taken
you don't need to I don't think you'd
need to to talk about the fact that
you're going to have someone
investigated for assault because why
would you be talking about that on a
municipal board if it applied to say
um
I don't know
their their job that might be part of it
if they were a police officer that
assaulted you or something I mean
I don't know where to go with that
that's just I think really getting into
the weeds
can I say something yeah sure what if we
do in amendment that includes the
officials and we changed this that it
says the person has and I you do the
legal stuff the person has the right to
notification prior to
any action being taken that means that
the poor the Town Council can get
together and chit chat about it for as
long and as many times as they want to
do it but before we decide that we're
going to tell
Lynn that he can't go into the library
anymore we're going to call him in and
he has a right to
give his side of the story okay okay no
that that okay and I understand that the
municipal
people Administration people feel that
that's an issue if you want to try
try to put in it that it says something
that only applies to you know Town
whatever whatever but I still think we
need something that is going to give
John Doe the right to know what he's
been accused of before
the town takes any type of
it doesn't have to be legal action it
could be action that you can't go into
the library or can't step on this or you
can't do that John Doe has a right to
know before because as soon as you call
a lawyer and as soon as you do this
action now John does put in the position
where
well I can't afford a lawyer I'm up the
creek so you know let's let's hear let's
find out what really happened
that's all all right let me let me try
to see if I can draft some language that
would accomplish accomplish that um
all right all right any any else anyone
else
anything else anyone wants to say thank
you all right great thank you thank you
we're done
see you next time guys gonna go